Transcription: Viji Gowri
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Commençons par un petit voyage
dans le temps.
Essayez de vous rappeler
vos 17, 18, 19 ans.
Vous êtes sur le point de vivre
votre première grande expérience seule.
Faire un grand voyage, partir
vous installer pour faire vos études.
Vous sentez cet air d’indépendance.
Les ailes déployées,
vous sentez libre,
enfin autonome.
Et puis, on va faire
le constat aujourd’hui.
Alors oui, je vous entends rire,
mais ça m'a fait le même effet.
20 ans après, j’ai fait le constat
que j’étais plutôt
une adulte en perte d’autonomie.
Alors oui, normalement les personnes
en perte d’autonomie vont directement
soit en maison de retraite,
soit ont une aide à domicile.
Pourtant, je suis une adulte
en perte d’autonomie pour deux raisons.
La première, c’est que
je suis  maman de deux petites filles.
Et puis, je me suis rendu compte
que mes journées
ressemblaient à un marathon.
Tout à coup, le temps
que j’avais quand j’avais 17 ans a disparu
et je me retrouve à avoir des journées
avec des timings
tellement serrés et à respecter
que le soir lorsque j’ouvre mon bouquin,
le petit temps que j’ai pour moi,
je relis cinq fois la même phrase
et je m’endors
et je recommence le lendemain.
Puis la deuxième raison, c’est que
mon attention s’est déplacée de moi.
À 17 ans, j’étais concentré
sur mes besoins, mes envies.
C'était le moment de déployer
mes propres ailes.
À 38 ans, mon attention est déplacée
sur mes 2 petites filles,
sur la vie de famille,
sur leurs besoins,
leur timing,
leurs nécessités,
leurs envies.
Mais voilà, il y a cinq ans,
j’ai fait une rencontre extraordinaire.
Je me suis retrouvé pour la première fois
dans un atelier de danse intégrante.
Alors bon, vous allez me dire,
rien de surprenant.
Je suis danseuse, je prends donc
des ateliers de danse intégrante
et des ateliers de danse.
Mais là, dans cet atelier,
tout était surprenant.
Déjà, la danse intégrante...
C’est une pratique qui a été créée
par le chorégraphe Eric Languet
avec sa compagnie,
la compagnie Danses en l’R
sur l’île de la Réunion.
Et dans cette pratique,
l’objectif, c’est de réunir,
durant une journée, quelques heures,
des danseurs à la fois
professionnels et amateurs,
des danseurs valides
et des danseurs en situation de handicap.
Et pour que nous puissions tous
être réellement en état de danse,
Eric nous propose un cadre
qui nous permet d’assumer nos différences,
de les concocter ensemble
pour un temps assez magique
où chacun retrouve l’espace de soi,
le temps de soi.
Alors là, ce soir, j’ai décidé
de partager avec vous cette recette.
Donc je vous propose
de mettre vos tabliers,
de retroussez vos manches
et on va passer en cuisine.
Alors on va commencer par les ingrédients,
c’est très, très simple.
Il ne faut pas grand-chose...
il faut seulement vous retrouver
avec des personnes
différentes de vous,
vos enfants, amis, famille, collègues,
des personnes
que vous ne connaissez pas - encore,
mais en chair et en os.
Vous vous retrouvez dans un même espace
et partagez cet espace-là .
Une fois que vous êtes réunis,
on va pouvoir passer
à la première étape de la recette :
ne pas aider une personne,
sauf
si elle vous le demande
ou comme dirait Michael,
ne m’empêchez pas de faire,
ne m’empêchez pas de danser.
Parce qu’en fait,
aider une personne
si elle ne l’a pas demandé,
c’est faire à sa place,
c’est l’empêcher de faire.
C’est faire à mon rythme
pour que ça aille à mon rythme
et pas au sien.
C’est le faire suivant
ma propre temporalité.
Ne pas aider une personne,
sauf si elle le demande,
c’est remettre le curseur sur soi-même.
Et on pourrait dire également
être là pour soi.
Je suis là pour moi.
Si tu as besoin d’aide,
tu me le dis
et tu es là pour toi.
Et si j'ai besoin d'aide, je te le dirai.
Alors tout à coup, les curseurs se replace
sur chacune de nos personnes
avec nos différences
et nos temporalités différentes.
Donc par exemple, quand on nous dit
on va faire un exercice
et vous allez au sol et vous vous relevez.
Moi, quand je fais ça,
je mets deux secondes,
puis pour me relever,
je mets deux secondes.
Puis Sylvette à côté de moi...
Elle, elle va mettre une minute,
peut-être deux
parce qu’elle va pousser son déambulateur,
elle va chercher son équilibre
et puis elle va aller au sol.
Moi, j’y serai peut-être allée
cinq, dix, quinze fois.
Elle l’aura fait une fois,
mais elle l’aura fait toute seule,
à son rythme
et c'est ok.
Nos deux temporalités peuvent se conjuguer
dans un même espace
et enrichir cet espace.
Alors une fois qu’on a
cette première étape,
on va pouvoir passer à la deuxième -
être honnête avec soi-même
et avec ses émotions.
Parce qu’en fait, quand on met le curseur
de nouveau sur soi,
on se rend compte qu’à l’intérieur,
il y a un sacré mouvement.
Parce qu’en fait,
on est habité tout le temps
d’émotions, de mouvement,
d’émotions en mouvement.
Parce que les émotions, ça vient, ça part,
ça change de niveau
tout le long de la journée.
Mais souvent notre curseur
est sur le côté,
sur les enfants, sur ce qu’on a à faire
et on ne fait pas attention
à ce qu’il se passe à l’intérieur.
Dans cet espace qu’on va partager,
si je reviens vers moi,
je prêterai à nouveau attention
à ce qu’il se passe en moi.
Je vais pouvoir ressentir
de la tristesse,
de la joie, être ému,
mais pouvoir aussi me sentir frustrée
si je n’arrive pas à faire quelque chose
ou si je ne comprends pas quelque chose.
Et là, j’ai la possibilité
de savoir si je suis disponible
pour partager cet espace
avec l’autre ou pas.
J’ai le droit d’être à la fois disponible
ou de ne pas l’être.
Très simple.
Si je suis disponible,
je continue à partager cet espace,
à échanger, à partager,
à construire ensemble.
Si tout à coup ce que je traverse
ne me permet pas d’être disponible,
je peux faire un pas de côté.
Ça ne veut pas dire
que je serai exclue, isolée.
J’ai le droit et à tout moment,
lorsque l’émotion sera passée,
je pourrai revenir.
Et ça, Éthan, au collège,
il avait très bien compris.
Éthan c’est un adolescent
en décrochage scolaire
et dans un atelier,
j’ai proposé qu’on fasse
de la danse contact
et pour Éthan,
le toucher   c’était impossible.
Et donc il a senti une émotion vraiment
très désagréable l’envahir
et il n’a pas eu besoin
de le verbaliser à qui que ce soit.
Il est en accord avec lui-même.
Il a fait un pas de côté
et il a regardé, le groupe travailler.
Et puis lorsque l’exercice était fini,
il est revenu dans le groupe
et c’était ok pour tout le monde, en fait.
Il avait cet espace-là,
il avait le droit d’être lui-même
en accord avec ses émotions.
Alors une fois qu’on en est là,
on va pouvoir passer
à la troisième étape -
être au meilleur de ses possibilités.
Alors on va rester au collège
parce qu’au collège, il faut le dire
qu’on est au meilleur de nos possibilités.
Donc soit on exploite ses possibilités,
son potentiel
et on se sent un peu exclu du groupe.
Soit on n’a pas trouvé notre potentiel
parce que l’espace qui nous est offert
ne nous permet pas de le rencontrer
et on est encore exclu du groupe
comme Éthan.
Et puis sinon, on va avoir besoin
de faire partie
parce qu’on a réellement
un besoin interne, un besoin humain,
c’est de faire partie d’un groupe,
se sentir inclus dans un groupe.
Et donc on va aller choisir
de ne pas trop montrer son potentiel
et de se lisser
pour appartenir
et donc faire
une moyenne assez médiocre.
Alors cette moyenne, elle fonctionne,
mais alors
ce n’est pas vraiment stimulant.
Ce n’est pas l’endroit où on va apprendre,
se nourrir, se dépasser, se surpasser,
sortir de sa zone de confort
et augmenter sa zone de confort.
Alors quand on va reposer le cadre,
être au meilleur de ses possibilités
en atelier par exemple,
c’est quand je rencontre Lionel.
Lionel est là, en fauteuil
et il ne peut danser,
il ne peut bouger que son bras gauche.
En début d’atelier, il me dit :
« Je ne sais pas ce que je fais là.
En fait, je ne peux pas danser ».
C’est car Lionel ne sait pas que
si on est tous les deux
au meilleur de nos possibilités,
il va se rendre compte que :
« Si, il sait danser ».
Alors, la première réaction que j’ai eu
dans mes premiers ateliers,
c’est de danser qu’avec mon bras gauche
parce que je n’osais pas être
au maximum de mon potentiel.
Je ne voulais pas montrer à Lionel
ce qu'il ne pouvait pas faire.
J'avais l'impression de le blesser.
Alors oui, on danse
avec notre bras gauche tous les deux.
Au bout d’une, deux, trois danses,
ça commence à devenir vraiment ennuyant.
Et puis il y a ce cadre,
cette proposition d’Eric,
être au meilleur de ses possibilités.
Que permet-il donc ?
Ça permet que tout à coup,
j’entre en relation avec Lionel
à travers toute la possibilité
de mon mouvement,
et puis pose sa main sur ma tête
et le contact de sa main sur ma tête
va diriger tout mon corps
et c’est tout mon corps
qui va réagir avec sa pose.
Il peut tirer, je suis sa main et je passe
cette information dans tout mon corps.
Et puis parfois ça va être l’inverse...
C’est ma tête qui va repousser son bras
et puis il va aller chercher le mouvement
dans l’épaule, dans le coude,
dans le poignet, dans la main.
Tout à coup,
il découvre mille possibilités
de mouvement avec un seul bras.
Et moi, je découvre plein de chemins
à travers juste ce contact sur ma tête,
comment ce mouvement peut
traverser mon corps.
Et là, tout à coup,
s’ouvre un nouveau champ des possibles
pour lui comme pour moi.
Alors une fois que la marmite bouillonne
et on est nourri de l’expérience
et de l’échange les uns avec les autres,
on va pouvoir passer à la quatrième étape.
Si on rencontre un problème,
on l'affronte.
Parce qu’on en rencontre toujours
des problèmes, de un,
et parce que parfois
on ne comprend pas
ou on ne sait pas comment faire.
Alors plusieurs possibilités.
Si vous avez bien suivi la recette,
la première possibilité,
en fait est timide.
Je peux demander de l’aide (rire)
si je n’ai compris...
Je peux demander de l’aide,
si je ne sais pas
si je ne vois pas ce qu’on peut faire ?
La deuxième,
si tout le monde est au meilleur
de ses possibilités autour de moi,
j’aurais des modèles,
des gens qui ont compris
et qui ont une manière
de trouver une solution
qui me propose une solution
qui est la leur.
Mais cette solution-là
devient inspirante pour moi.
Je peux me dire :
« Voilà, un chemin »
et je vais essayer de trouver
ma propre solution
juste par le fait
d’être entouré de personnes
au meilleur de leurs possibilités.
Et puis la troisième possibilité,
c’est également
que je suis entouré d’autres.
Puis qu’on peut choisir, définir ensemble,
poser le fait qu’il y a un problème
et trouver ensemble une solution.
Alors par exemple, avec Serge...
Serge est non-voyant.
Lorsqu’on fait les ateliers,
on commence souvent
par juste un exercice d’écoute.
Marcher.
Lorsque quelqu'un s'arrête,
tout le monde s'arrête.
Lorsque quelqu'un repart,
tout le monde repart.
Mais vous voyez bien le problème
si Serge ne me voit pas m’arrêter,
il ne pourra pas s’arrêter.
Alors en discutant avec le groupe,
en leur laissant la possibilité
de définir eux,
une solution.
Ils ont défini la solution suivante
qui leur appartient,
qu’ils répètent à chaque atelier.
C’est devenu un code commun
à ce groupe-là.
Lorsque quelqu’un s’arrête,
la personne la plus proche
va s’approcher de Serge
et poser sa main sur son épaule.
Puis quand le groupe repart,
la personne la plus proche
glisse sa main sur le bras de Serge.
Serge sait qu’il peut repartir.
Tout à coup, il est autonome
d’aller à son propre rythme,
de choisir les directions
et en même temps,
il fait partie du groupe.
Alors voilà, on a une recette
avec des ingrédients très simples.
Vous êtes les ingrédients-là,
dans cette salle.
Première étape, n’aider une personne
que si elle demande.
La deuxième, être honnête avec soi même
et avec ses émotions.
La troisième,
être au meilleur de ses possibilités
et la quatrième,
si je rencontre un problème,
je l’affronte.
Alors maintenant,
c’est à vous d’aller en cuisine.
Donc je vous propose vraiment
de prendre le temps pour chaque étape.
Prenez le temps
de faire mijoter tout ça
à l’intérieur de vous,
avec vos proches,
au lointain,
et puis de savourer
cet air d’autonomie
qui va venir infuser dans vos vies
et dans celle des personnes
qui vous entourent.
Merci.